Two thousand years
after his assassination,
he is still revered as
one of the greatest real,
as in all of history.
Yet his story reverberates as a tale
of the dangers of power on bounds.
It is military genius and political
skill saw him rise to the position of
dictator for life,
but it all came to a bloody end.
On the ides of March.
In this week's biographics,
we discovered the man who was
Caesar Goddess Julius Caesar
was born on either the twelfth or
13th of July in the year 100 bce.
His was a patrician family,
which historically had political sway
but was not influential at the time of
Jesus' birth.
His Father Gaius was a prenatal
or an elected magistrates,
and it was the governor
of the province of Asia.
While his mother or really I belonged
to a family of some prominence.
Seizes on.
Julio was the wife of Gas Marius,
who was the leader of the popular faction.
Political movements.
We don't know very much
about Caesar's childhood,
but his education included the study of
the Greek language and he read the works
of Greek historians in his early teens.
He began attending lectures
on philosophy and rhetoric,
showing a keen interest in developing
his skills as a public speaker.
At the time,
this was something of a
price stability in Rome.
The Roman forum was the center of
intellectual discussion and debate in Rome
during seasons youth.
It was there that political ideas were
argued out where questions were discussed
in elections,
held any man who has ambition as a master,
the skill of holding the
attention of their audience,
and Julius Caesar,
he was showing himself to be a
young man of quite some ambition.
Tragedy struck disease.
A household,
though in 85 ce when Ghia senior died,
suddenly the 16 year old Julius
was now the head of the family.
He inherited this leadership at the very
time that civil war was breaking out
between the popular faction,
led by his uncle Gaius Marius
and his political rival,
Lucius,
Cordelia Sula after a
bitter and bloody struggle,
see,
like gains the ascendancy.
Gus,
he was exiled to Africa and
he died shortly thereafter
with similar now in power.
Those who had ties to Gaius.
Marius were put under pressure,
having married the daughter of a
prominent member of the popular faction,
Cornelia the team sees a.
He became a bit of a target,
see little ordered that he break off
the marriage and distance himself from
Gaius.
Marius sees a refused and twist prescribed
by a similar meaning that he was
marked to the executed.
The 18 year old Caesar was
now forced into hiding.
It was only the influence
of his mother's family.
The led to see like lifting
this death sentence still,
Cesar was understandably of Sula.
He decided to do it,
be safe for him to be away from Rome
while Sula road the city sees it now,
set his sights on a military career.
Initially he served under Marcus Minimus,
thermos.
He proved to be a natural soldier serving
with distinction in the provinces of
Asia and Cilicia.
In 79 BC,
he was awarded the oak leaves of the
civic crown for saving the life of a
citizen in the heat of battle.
Things is rising.
Military Statute led to him being chosen
as an emissary to the king of the at
Nicodemus in order to exact a
promise for a fleet of ships.
He was successful in its mission,
how rumors spread that he had only managed
to persuade the gang by agreeing to
something
defender.
In 78 BC,
he died opening the way for season
two to Ryan having left the army.
He began a career as a legal advocate
with his inheritance having been
confiscated during the reign of Sila.
He and his wife live a modest lifestyle
and the lower class neighborhoods of
Sabira.
Three of his legal representations
season began to develop a reputation as a
powerful and passionate
public speaker in 75 bce.
While on his way to advance
his studies in Greece,
Caesar was kidnapped by Sicilian
pirates and held for ransom.
It is reputed that when the pirates told
it and they had demanded 20 talents for
his release,
he was insulted and insisted that
they increase it to 50 talents.
He was treated well by the pirates
and has a relaxed time with them.
However,
the the ransom was paid
and he was released.
He vowed to them that he would hunt
them down and have them crucified.
He was good to his word raising group of
volunteers and overpowering his former
capitalist prior to their execution,
yet the pirates throats carts as a show
of leniency for having treated him well.
Shortly after his pirate escapade.
Caesar was recalled into military service
he was sending to the province of Asia
and tasked with raising a volunteer
force to put down a rebellion.
Upon successful completion
of this mission,
he returned to Rome and was duly
appointed as a military tribune.
It was the first step
of his political career.
Season was not shy about espousing
his support for the popular faction,
which had been put down by Sulla years
before he took on the prominent case of a
reigning the governor of
Macedonia dollar Bella,
who had been closely associated with Suda.
When the trial came,
Caesar appeared at the forum,
the force and vigor with which he rated
his argument sweating great public
support in opposing dollar.
Bella sees it was positioning
himself as the people's champion.
He was increasingly being seen as the
natural inheritor of Marius in order to
head up the popular faction with Suna
supporters still in the ascendancy,
however,
Dolabella was acquitted,
but the case had made Julia Caesar,
one of the most conspicuous
men in all of Rome.
Caesar loved the prominence
that he was receiving.
He began to take on the character
of the leader of the Popular Party.
He spoke fluently in the forum both
before assemblies and in the courts of
justice.
It is legal role.
He came to specialize in defending those
who were accused of political crimes
through his energy and his boldness,
not to mention the strength of logic
and reasoning that he demonstrated.
He became the rising champion of the
people when Caesar's onto the wife of
Marius Julia dive.
He arranged to hold a prominent
funeral for her since the time of the
suppression of our husbands and the potty.
He headed junior,
had lived in obscurity,
in fact,
any who associated with were
putting their lives in danger.
Yet the fearless Caesar said there's
a flattering funeral oration from the
rostrum of the forum.
He went as far as condemning the ouster
of his uncle and producing images of
Marius for the crowd to see that this
says Patricia partisans in the audience.
They began to objects,
but they were shouted down by the crowd.
Before long Caesar was delivering
another funeral oration.
This time it was his own wife,
Cornelia,
who had died in delivering the oration.
He made the points of praising a family
who had been prominent members of the
popular family in both funeral oration.
He emphasized the ancient ability of his
family claiming descends from the first
king on his mother's side and from
the gods on his father's side.
Following the funeral for his wife,
sees a was appointed as a crestal,
a position which involved performing
financial auditing duties.
He traveled to Spain where he
served as creatorship and 69 bce.
It.
It said that while in Spain,
he came across a statue
of Alexander the Great's,
which caused him to reflect on
this life's accomplishments.
To date,
he was now 32 the same age at which
Alexander had managed to achieve well
dominance.
In comparison.
He had achieved nothing of significance.
He resolved to change that situation.
Upon returning to Rome,
seizes,
prominence and popularity,
soar,
and being elected to a
succession of public offices.
Then in 67 BC,
he was appointed to the Senate.
In that same year,
he married the granddaughter
of Sula Palm Payer.
The marriage only lasted six years with
Caesar divorcing her when she became
caught up in a damaging political scandal.
In 67 bce,
Caesar was appointed as
a formal magistrates.
Around this time,
it began to engage in the popular custom
of cementing public favor by staging a
lavish entertainment spectacles.
These included games with wildebeests
and gladiators being brought in from all
over the realm.
These extravagant displays serve that
purpose of making a extremely popular with
the masses,
but they also put a huge
strain on his finances.
In fact,
they punched him into debt.
The only way that you could possibly
extricate himself from his financial woes
was by rising to a
position of ultimate power.
In 63 bce,
Caesar set his sights on the position
of Pontifex maximus or chief priest.
He spends even more borrowed money on
popular support and despite being opposed
by two powerful senators,
he won the position
handily the following year.
He was appointed as appropriate or pro
magistrate and an area of southern before
you could take up the position.
However,
he was required to settle his
outstanding debts for this,
he turns to one of the city's richest men,
marcus,
the skinniest crassus grasses agreed
to help sees a financially on the basis
that he would in turn,
provide political influence
in [inaudible] favor,
sees now travel to Spain,
but he proved to be a
successful administrator you
have to give to both military
and financial success.
We're tending to rhyme with enough
money to pay off all of his debts,
sees a.
He was now in a position to satisfy
sites on the highest political office in
Rome.
The office of console when the Romans
had gotten rid of their line of kings.
They had vested sea pre magistracy
in the hands of two consoles.
These men were chosen each
year in the general election.
It was left to the people sees,
would have had no problem gaining the
needed votes such while says popularity
among them.
However,
there were a number of
influential political rivals
who opposed him at the time.
There was a buser rivalry unfolding
between two men have great influence upon
pay.
Crassus Bombay was a great military leader
while crashes held influenced you to
as wealth sees a conceived of the plan
to unite them and they get both of them
tobacco in for consult.
He succeeded brilliantly in his plan
managing to create a triumvirate of the
three most influential
politicians in Rome,
each of whom was bound to advance the
political elevation of the others in order
to secure his alliance with Pompei
Caesar arranged for his only daughter,
Juliet,
you enter into a marriage alliance.
Lance with palm paved with the support
of crisis and Palm Bay behind him.
Caesar set about securing his
appointment to the console.
It's political.
Opponents knew that they would be unable
to prevent public support from securing
the console ship for Caesar,
so they set their sights on
preventing seizes preferred console.
A man named Lucius from achieving office.
They put forward bitterness.
He was a political opponent
to Caesar for the position,
sees a ambivalence,
were elected co consoles for the 59 bce.
However,
Caesar immediately proceeded to ignore
his colleague assuming full power in
carrying out measures unilaterally that
were geared to ingratiate himself with
the People Caesar was opposed by
leading members of the sentence.
One of his famous deponent's
with Keto fervent patriot.
He was incensed that Caesar's unilateral
decision making at one point sees the
ordered that Keto be taken into custody
and thrown in prison as he was being
escorted out by God's another influential
senator rose to accompany him.
When Caesar asked where he was going,
he replied to that he would rather be
in prison with Keto than in the Senate.
With Caesar seizes.
Control of the console
ship was so complete,
so this is supposed to go.
Console,
gave up entirely retiring to his
house and leaving Caesar Free Reign
sees a follow dizzier is consoled by
reimbursing upon his military career by
achieving great military conquest.
He would ensure that his
star rose even higher.
His powerful political allies helped
Caesar secure proconsul ship over three
provinces for an unprecedented
five year governorship.
He became governor of illyricum in the
Balkins Sisyphean goal in northern Italy
and translating goal in southern France
sees this first opportunity for conquest
came when southeastern Gould was invaded
by a tribe known as the Helvetica,
sees a moved against them with six and
agents and crushed them during a fisk
five our battle.
He then turned his attention
to the Germanic tribes.
Despite the formidable
reputation of these warriors,
the Roman legions managed to defeat
them at the battle of Valascus.
By 57 bce,
Caesar had built his
army to eight legions,
numbering some 40,000 men.
He knows that channel to subjugate the
Belgrade tribes decimating each one
individually before they
could unite against him.
The final victory came
at the battle of sadness,
by which time season it
completely conquered the golf
course with his power now
unquestioned within his own territory,
seasoned now began looking
beyond known borders.
He set his sights on
Germania and pertaining Ya.
In 55 BC,
he built a bridge across
the Rhine in record.
Ten days having it dismantled when he
recrossed after spending 18 days probing
the countryside,
a similar scouting mission was made into
Britannia later that same year in 54
BC,
he returns with a full five legions
with the objective of establishing a
permanent Raymond base that the Britains
though I had other ideas and they
continually harassed the raymonds
with a hit and run attacks strategy.
Still the determination of their leader
and the discipline of their rank and
file enabled.
The Romans do systematically
hunt down the local resistance.
And as the Britains sued for peace season,
negotiated an annual tribute,
took a swath of hostages,
and then left.
Never set foot on British soil again.
In 53 BC,
a goldish revolts was quickly put down,
but a year later or more determined and
better organized revolt occurred under
the leadership of verse and get direct,
say powerful warrior who was determined
to kick the Romans out of goal,
set out to crush the revolt with
a full compliment of 10 legions.
After suffering a number of losses.
Verse and Gatorade switched to a scorched
earth policy that's going to go via
the Romans suffered their first defeat.
There's revenge came swiftly
at the battle of Alicia.
The revolt was crushed and get her ex
was taken alive and transport a jerome
where it was paraded in a
cage like a wild animal.
Then in 47 bce,
Caesar embarked on a voyage to Turkey
in order to take care of pharmacies.
The seconds it had been extending his
power by over powering a number of
neighboring Roman states
with just three legions,
Caesar went directly to the
town of Zilla to face fantasies.
The Romans took off a strong
position on the hilltop.
The Turkish revolt was
put down in quick order,
giving rise to seizes.
Most famous quotes,
Veni Vidi Vc.
I came,
I saw I conquered.
Over the next two years,
Caesar put down rebellions
in North Africa and Hispania
during his years in military campaigns,
Caesar sauce to continue influencing
Roman politics through his supporters.
In 50 bce,
he met with his old allies,
this and pompey in order to
renew their triumvirate alliance.
Over the next few years,
however,
the alliance,
it broke down in 53 bce.
Crassus was killed in battle.
Meanwhile,
Pompei was distancing himself
from season about this time.
Julia died during childbirth.
Further fragmenting the
relationship between the two men.
When Ross interrupted in and 52 BC,
pompey was appointed to the
consult without colleague.
He quickly aligns himself
with the ultimate faction
of Arris to crat suit where
post to Caesar the following year with
Caesar's military conquest having been
completed.
The optimists warns him that
if he returned to the room,
it would be immediately arrested for
excesses of office during his years as
consult within the city.
They had developed popular factions
in supportive both pompey and Caesar.
The lasses follow his attempted to have
him voted to the console in absentia,
but the opposition demanded that he first
returned to face the music and give up
the commands of his army sees
the bulks at least amounts.
He knew it now that there
was only one recourse.
He had to march on Rome and claim
what he rightfully saw as his.
On January the 10th to 49 bce.
He marched a single lesion across the
Rubicon River which marked the border of
his province.
This was an immediate active civil war.
Yes,
there will be my battle Pompei with
most of his forces deployed in Spain,
fled to the south.
This enabled Caesar's march on Rome on
hindered that he had himself declared
dictator with this top general
Mark Anthony as second in
command in short order.
He was elected to the console ship at
which time he resigned his dictatorship
season.
Now,
so touts in pursuit of Pompei,
leaving Mark Antony and control of Rome.
My now pumping had established himself
in Greece and was building a four steam
challenge.
Caesar in 48 bce,
the two armies,
Matt's on the plains of fossil.
This with pompey's forces
outnumbering those of of two to one.
However,
Caesar one by employing superior tactics,
Pohnpei,
though he managed to escape to Egypt,
sees a pursued palm bay to Alexandria.
There he was supposed to be handed the
head of his adversary who had betrayed
the Egyptians and paid the ultimate price.
Just prior to his arrival in Alexandria,
the joint reload 21 year old Cleopatra
had been driven from the city.
She had a self smuggled in diseases
presence inside a rolled up rug.
She besieged him for assistance
in regaining the throne.
The Raymond Nita saw Cleopatra as a
useful future ally integrated to support
that a prolonged Egyptian
siege of Alexandria followed.
Czo ordered the Egyptian fleets to be
burned and managed to hold off a force of
around 20,000 for several months.
He sent a rhyme for reinforcements
and when they turned up,
he marched out to join
them in the ensuing battle.
The Egyptians were defeated.
Cleopatra was installed as Pharaoh and
after spending a further two months
enjoying her company,
sees a began fee,
return Jenny to Rome.
On his way back.
He even put down a
rebellion in Asia Minor.
During his absence,
things had not gone well in Rome,
largely due to Marc Antony,
ms dot managements,
employing great diplomatic skills.
Season managed to overcome a potential
navy mutiny and put down a rebellion by
the optimists
season was now appointed dictator for
10 years at the height of his powers.
And enjoying unprecedented public support.
He ruled autocratically.
This goal is great business among
the senators who we ignored.
Primary among the dissenters
were the two sons of Pompeii,
sexists and miss.
These do headed to Spain,
implemented a revolt that
Caesar was forced to travel
to Spain to personally put
down the rebellion.
In February 44 BC,
Caesar was appointed dictator Pettius.
During the ceremony,
he refused to wear the diadem
that Marc Antony handed to him,
stating that Jupiter was the
only for king if the Romans,
Ethan prepared to lead a military
campaign against the Parthians.
Prior to his planned departure from Rome,
Caesar attended a final
meeting of the Senate.
It was on the 15th of March,
44 bce,
unknown disease at 60 of his most bitter
rivals in the centers has come to the
meeting with daggers concealed under
that togas Caesar entered the chamber and
proceeded to make his
way to his golden chat.
Other designated signal senators,
rules,
directions leapt upon him as the
first dagger blow came down upon him,
Caesar was hard to cry out.
Why this violence to avid
supporters tried to come to his aid,
but they were blocked by the
conspirators within limits,
had been stabbed 23 times.
His final act was to cover his face
with his toga so that none would see his
death expression.
Cesar died at the feet
of a statue of pompey.
The conspirators wanted to throw
his body into the Tiber river,
that they were stopped by Marc Antony.
The announcement that Caesar was dead.
It was met with rioting by the people
and to the conspirators were forced to
flee.
The city sees his body was cremated with
the Temple of Caesar being built on the
cremation site.
From that point on,
the legend of the martyred Caesar would
be passed down through the centuries.
So I really hope you enjoyed that video.
If you did,
don't forget to subscribe to this channel
for brand new biographies every Monday
and every Thursday.
Also,
I've got another channel
that's called today.
I found out it's sort of like biographics,
but way more broad on that channel.
We get deep into all of the details
on all sorts of interesting stuff.
Check it out through the
link on the screen now,
but if you look into something
else to watch right now,
why not check out a biography from the
archives or is it al found out video over
there on the right,
and as always,
thank you for watching.